s
rendez-vous d'information
qui seront au coeur de
sa progr.
Louis-Philippe Ouimet.
(rires)
- Les chefs d'antenne sont prêts
pour un automne qui sera marqué
par la campagne électorale
québécoise. Patrice Roy animera
et la soirée électorale
en direct de la nouvelle
Maison de Radio-Canada.
PATRICE ROY, journaliste et
chef d'antenne, Téléjournal
faire la soirée dans l'atrium,
c'est grandiose. En même t
le pari, c'est de pas perdre
de vue que les gens parlent
avec les yeux. Donc, ça va és,
d'humains, d'émotions,
de défaites, de vi
une soirée électorale,
c'est beaucoup ça.
- Toute la journée
leurs annonces...
- Au Téléjournal de
Céline Galipeau, on surveillera
de près les villes baromètres
et on dinés en région.
CÉLINE GALIPEAU, journaliste et
chef d'antenne, Téntenne, Ténteh
- "Cinq par cinq", c'est
cinq enjeux, cinq régions,tes,t,
cinq partis. Bon, on a essayé
ifier les choses pour
que les gens s'en rappellent.
Mais dans les faits, c'est
un peu voir ce qui se passeaillu
dans les régions.
- En plus des élections,nada
s'intéressera à l'inflation.
GÉRALD FILLION, journaliste et
chef d'antenne, "Zone économie"
- Nous, on prépare sur l'inf sut
la récession : "De l'inflation
à la récession?" C'est jeudi
25 août. Et une émission
spéciale principaux candidats
des principaux partis.
- Il sera aussi question,
au cours des prochains mois,
et de la pandémie. L'émission
"24/60" va célébrer sa 15e
saison dans son nouveau studio.
ANNE-MARIE DUSSAULT, journaliste
- Alors, je vais paraphraser
certains politiciens : C'est
qui ai le plus beau studio!
Alors, évidemment, ça permet
parce qu'il y a différents
plateaux, un plate
intime.
- Aux affaires publiques,
va célébrer sa 35e saison;
"La facte saison;e saison;e sai;
tandis que pour sa 21e saison,
"L'épicerie" accueille
Myriam Fehmiu.
JOHANE D-animatrice
de l'émission "L'épicerie"
- C'est bien stimulant.
d'avoir du nouveau,
n qui arrive
avec des nouvelles idées,
une nouvelle façon de penser
- Télé, radio, web;l'informl'int
plus que jamais multiplateforme.
LUCE JULIEN, direcà Radio-Canada
- Le public est toujours là,tour
les médias traditionnels.
Cela étant, c'est fondamental
qu'on soit présent
sur les réseaux sociaux,
qu'on ait le laboratoire
de journalisme RAD,
qui continue d'innover.
- L'automne sera très occupé...
- Avec des cotes d'écoute
record, l'information
de Radio-Canada est sur
une lancée, au grand bonheur
de ses journalistes.
qu'on met autant d'énergiedans s
nous suivent. Alors, tant mieux
et on croise les dléspectateurs.
- Ici Lo